hey what's up beautiful babies welcome
to another episode of get close I am
your co-host Geo and I'm Bart and
recently we've been taking a what is it
called a walk through memory lane and
we're looking at some of our old videos
like even before the podcast like our
old Bell talks like all the OG fans will
remember where it's just me and Geo
after hours at the JK office sitting
side by side because there were no these
cool like equipment yet and we had a lot
of uh we were podcasting before
podcasting was a thing yeah we were
podcasting when Joe Rogan was barely
making podcasting cool yeah yeah and
they were short form you know like just
little quick topics and stuff and uh Geo
recently stumbled upon this game that we
were gonna play personally yeah but as
you started reading me some of the
questions I was like oh this really
reminds me of our old Bell talk videos
except these questions are better
because there a little bit more
thoughtful yeah yeah
um yeah so I was randomly trying to find
family games ironically enough because I
just like when we get to I don't know
play with taika and I we like board
games we had JK party and I was like oh
that'd be so cool to have like that
could be the next Generation uh and then
randomly it popped up and I'm like oh my
God we need to do this we need to
connect us a couple more especially at
night because we just work so much
together and we parent so much together
that like I've been feeling like you and
I relationship-wise we just haven't been
having that connection time
um so found this game or I guess it's
just like talking topics and one of the
ones that I liked I haven't even read to
you because I was like kind of asking
you some questions you're like these are
great so one of the ones
um I that kind of just resonated with me
is letting it go versus confronting your
partner how do you make these choices in
dealing with me why do you say that well
it's a good one why do you say that why
is it good well it's good because
um
remember how
I'm [__]
you're not okay but remember how I am
and during one of the darkest moments of
our relationship maybe like 20 I don't
know 13 2014.
um David was kind of like uh kind of
like a mediator kind of like a
translator and then kind of like uh it's
the best but don't you dare tell him I
ever said that fine but he kind of helps
like
I think mainly me see like the human
side of things right so one of the
things he always talks about during
those times robots yeah one of the
things he always talks about back then
is he's like you gotta pick and choose
your battles oh I don't remember that I
know you don't remember [__] I don't but
he'd always say like you gotta pick and
choose your battles
um because I'm such a robot that if
anything's not Computing you know like
when you type in something like one
divided by zero like your calculator
will show error error error right well
like so when things aren't Computing I'm
like I'm stuck on it I can't move
forward what what what is that and then
David would be like but is that even
important yes thank you David okay last
time she said she loves cherry soda now
she ordered seven up at the restaurant
it's your anniversary maybe the
anniversary is more important than you
going wait I thought you said you love
cherries Cherry Soda body onion Sprite
this time that's so true you do that all
the time so he would say pick and choose
your battles right yeah so that was
something I learned
big time I'm like oh okay this is how
like humans like to operate there's like
like big problems small problems you
gotta prioritize it and it has and it
has made things way way smoother on my
end that's so funny and it's not even
something I think about you know because
I think you're a human being intuitively
or just yeah because of just how I was
raised yeah
that I didn't even realize that I was
already doing the like picking and
choosing my battles where I'm like is
that even important like does it even
matter let's just move on yeah but so
either I'm like
I'm [__] Autistic or some [__] but I
don't know what the [__] going because
even yesterday right or the other day
like you're like you're like fancy and
tell me all these things and then I
would like and really do the guy thing
try to solve your problems right and you
go don't solve my problems don't tell me
something you even send me clips of like
other like marriage family therapists
you don't need to solve problems you
they just want you to hear them out and
you want to be able to be on the same
page and that helps relieve the stress
right I'm like okay cool don't solve
problems you have to label they say it's
like oh you sound exhausted or you sound
frustrated and then the mix of the woman
go oh yeah and they relax right well
it's not even for women this is
something also
um that you'll find in you read this
book too uh uh How to Win Friends and
Influence People yeah it's the same
thing you just have to allow people to
talk things out they don't necessarily
um want you to solve their problems it's
just they just need to hear themselves
kind of sort through it and most of the
time like 90 of the time people already
know know what they need to do good so I
filed that right hey and then you're
like
all day oh lower back is kind of tight
oh my lower back is sore or my feet hurt
we've been standing all day huh and then
you're just laying in bed and I'm like
oh yeah and I'm like practicing it don't
solve problems oh yeah your back does
sound really tight oh my God sounds very
fatigued and then it wasn't until the
last minute give me a massage
[__] I'm like you literally told
me not to solve your problems and then
here you are
asking me to solve your problems so for
me this human thing
is quite difficult
yeah yeah I mean um I can see how it's
confusing right because like oh yeah now
you're forcing me to like
categorize things for you and be like no
no this is called like nurturing or this
will be the rules I know but like some
people will definitely understand you
and some people will definitely
understand me like right now you and I
were split and I feel like a lot of
people are going to be split
um the unreasonable people will
understand you for sure because they
want their minds to be red no it's not
unreasonable it's just there's just a
different emotional
aspect to it that you're just not very
keen to that's all yeah yeah well
anyways so i s this is my long-winded
way of saying yes I have learned to pick
and choose my battles and now the way
that I go about what do what things do I
confront did you forget the topic
already no no I didn't you mere human no
I didn't because it was so interesting
to me I was like wow did I read this
wrong because the way you interpreted
this question versus how I interpreted
it uh was very different so I was just
like whoa that's very interesting it's
the wrong way you interpreted it [__]
you one
um so when I read this letting it go
versus confronting your partner
um I was thinking more so how we deal
with our problems right like you're
someone that likes to when there is an
issue you like to deal with it right
then and there like hey let's just nip
it in the bud right now what is going on
let's talk about it and then the way I
like to do it is yes I'll confront it
but I need time so then I go okay wait
give me like a few minutes or give me
like an hour just so I can kind of sort
through my motions and then we'll sit
down and we'll discuss it but what's the
key word is it when or is it how
um so it says letting it go versus
confronting your partner how do you make
these choices in dealing with me how
okay so we're both right or wrong
well I don't know I that's just how I
took it I see the first time yours is
more of the method mine is more of the
deciding factor yeah so that's why um
when you when you were answering it I
was like whoa that's so cool like we got
this question and the interpretation was
absolutely different and then I was like
okay so I'm the type of person that will
blame myself first before I blame the
other person good good shut the hell up
you're so rude am I yeah not really I'm
just playing but
here we go but
um so because I always think I'm wrong
first I wanted to check myself and I was
like what the [__] is your problem I got
your back labeling so then not solving
your problems
so then that's when I went to read it I
was like damn did I [__] up here and
then no I didn't that's all I was doing
and then you had to call me out like the
son of a [__] that you are yeah so the
way I interpreted it is like how do you
pick and choose your battles and for me
I think this actually has what David has
said has really really helped me because
um
now I kind of go like I'm able to kind
of distill the importance of the moment
and I've actually that has actually
helped me even be a better father too oh
yeah so like like let's say the whole
stupid like soda example obviously
that's like that's an exaggeration and
it's not that crazy what soda example
like the Cherry Soda you said cherry
soda is your favorite and the next time
you order Sprite all of a sudden yeah
and you're like perplexed like like
whatever I can compute what happened I
can't be in the moment now that it's our
like 10 year anniversary because I'm
still stuck in that right so when we
have our um
like little
discrepancies or disputes or whatever I
keep that
in my mind now so like let's say let's
say you have this rule of like you
always gotta like I don't know just do
some stereotypical one some toilet seat
thing always got to do the toilet seat X
and then like let's say we're planning
on going on a really CUNY vacation to
like Yosemite or something
usually
had I gone to the bathroom and I go oh
she said X on the toilet seat and
today's why I'd be like
excuse me you said X on the toilet seat
but today it is why what is going on
right versus what is the moment the
moment is it's spring break it's
beautiful we've been talking about going
to Yosemite the all of last week today
we're gonna pack our little cooler full
of all the stickers on there load up the
truck have a happy trip all of that
would go out so now
um when I have like a
issue or a discrepancy in my mind that
comes up I go I try to like go well like
slow it down
what is the true nature of what is going
on right now you do you say that stuff
to yourself yeah yeah and if there's a
bigger like um a bigger battle to be
played or whatever I always go with that
so like let's say if it is Yosemite trip
or a big thing I'll be like
you know what it's not [__] important
and then so I won't confront you on
stuff like that the things that I will
confront are I would say like kind of
like the pillars of what holds our
relationship together I feel like
everybody's like relationship they have
like their pillars right like I really
respect the loyalty between these two or
I really like our fun times like every
single couple kind of has like their
main values that they really really
share yeah
so to me if it's a main value theme then
that is the relationship and if it is
the relationship that I don't really
give a [__] what else is going on I will
have to confront that especially if it's
one of those main things that I feel
like is going to take us back to like
the dark times yeah yeah
okay that's so that's how I kind of pick
and choose my battles now where I go is
that important it's not important is it
something
more important at play and then even if
it's something that like because you
know sometimes like the surface level
things feel so [__] annoying I feel
like you have to address it
did you ever give me an example because
maybe I'm do I'm addressing it every
time maybe you are on my end like like
let's say like uh
some surface level [__] okay so this is
a running joke in the house
you always think I'm not doing [__]
no I don't really think you're not doing
it exactly that's what I'm saying
running joke okay you gotta listen okay
yeah I'm sorry I I tried to listen to
you but you just annoy me okay good so
the running joke in the house is I don't
do [__] in the home
um but I feel like I'm always literally
picking up after you always literally I
love those words so much always
literally so because I'm never ever
because I'm always
like picking up after me literally
picking up after infinity times
that you feel that is this a running
joke or is that how you really feel
that's how I feel oh that's how I feel
but
um
like the other day you made some food
and you literally left it in the pan for
like three days straight and I'm like I
don't know why or the rice cooker is
still plugged in I don't know why but
anyways it's not important it's part of
the joke so shut the [__] up that is
actually driving me crazy because I you
helped me make rice yesterday when I was
picking up our sun your rice I can't
even afford rice so I don't know why
it's still in the [__] rice cooker
can I finish yeah of course okay thank
you so much uh so I asked you hey as I
go pick up our son like I do 90 of the
time from school can you please help me
by making some white rice yeah I cook
myself and our son some lunch we had
this Yummy Teriyaki chicken with white
rice good I know I'm rubbing it in your
face because the chicken that I ended up
putting away at night too because it was
left out and I was like can I finish is
she trying to make this rot on purpose
no can I finish excuse me can I finish
you have my permission
I don't need your [__] permission
I don't want to [__] be entrupted
anymore so I'm gonna finish okay
son of a [__]
so then
um I was gonna put everything away and
I'm like why do I do this to myself the
rice cooker's gonna or the rice is gonna
be so [__] hot right now I'm just
gonna wait and I'll do it tomorrow and
it but it bothers me waiting uh for me
to put it away more than 24 hours like
that it's sitting there is it plugged in
still yes so this has been bothering so
you're gonna let it cool off by keeping
it plugged in
no no no no yeah but it had just
finished I'm talking about today now
well today I do it I'm letting it cool
down overnight I unplug it so it cools
down overnight yeah but then it's gonna
get dry anyway you have your method I
have mine okay apparently according to
this card we do have different methods
you are such a can I finish you're so
annoying
you need to shut up I swear to God if
you don't shut up Mia remember that
attack command we're gonna use that
straight to the balls no she's listening
okay fine okay I'm gonna tell her the
word
[__] in Spanish you just wait
Cooper's coming back in like a week
anyway so yeah it's been bothering me
I've been thinking about it all the time
in terms of the chicken I it was still
hot so I left it out and I'm sorry I was
taking care of all the house doing the
bed putting everything away there's
probably dishes in the sink because I
just didn't do it but I'm always
cleaning up after your stupid crusty ass
okay
I don't even know what just happened but
you pissed me off so much and I think
that's your [__] method I just
figured it out you piece of [__] you
interrupt me so that you can Sidetrack
me and get me over all dub and I can't
even think straight right now because
you keep interjecting interrupting me
and like being all sidewinding and [__]
and like trying to be funny and now I
can't remember what the [__] I was
trying to say Well done you son of a
[__] it's not a plan but anyways going
back to what I was saying how um you
feel like you look after me and uh
what's the word
like um put things away I feel like I do
the same for you barely okay but I'm
just saying that's how I feel
your feelings are wrong
when I put things
uh away
when I like take care of your [__]
in that moment I'm like [__]
but to me like the way that I gauge it
I'm like is this important to bring up
or is this something that's just gonna
happen the rest of our relationship and
if it is I just deal with it so because
of that like that's why I never confront
you about any of those things so because
that to me it's like little battles you
know okay
that's your son of a [__]
like you literally will eat lunch you
were done why do you keep it to
the examples are endless you literally
like eat lunch like you'll make food
and I don't know what happened but you
know the [__] uh
like when people come into the house
they just [__] kick their chocolates
all over the place you start throwing
their hats and [__] like when you cook
that's how you leave the kitchen and
then you finish eating and you just
throw everything in the sink and then
you walk away that's not even true
everything is all spatulas upside down
that's not even true upside down
straight up sauces will be unscrewed
like we've had I've seen [__] ketchup
dry in our kitchen
you're so [__] exaggerated I'm like
you're [__] exaggerated don't make me
expose your stupid ass by putting out
all our [__] Nest videos because the
way I like to operate you're probably
talking about one percent of the time
when I'm just so [__] over constantly
cleaning that I'm like you know what
today I'm gonna give myself a break so
the way I like to operate when I'm like
[__] working at Peak optimal level is
as soon as I cook I wait for things to
to cool off I'll eat I clean everything
and before I leave there's no dishes in
the sink that's how I operate I even
clean up all of the counter and the
[__] sink holder the [__] what
what's that chick called what is [__]
called the strainer yes I even cleaned
the food out of that I scrub the inside
of our sink
you don't even know what that is you
don't even pay attention to that [__] I
literally do that like every other day
oh my God
you know what your [__] cop-out is
what and and this is and I have a really
uh I have a good follow-up question but
your ass is interrupting and you just
want all the smoke so I'm giving you all
the stuff
but your ass your cop out and I'm like I
try to give you I try to cut you some
slack you're like Mama I can't do it
right now because you know I have ADHD
and I can only focus one thing at a time
please don't make me go back and like
have to do this and I'm like okay fine
this [__] crazy [__] address
me goddamn crazy has ADHD so he can't he
can't multitask the way I can so I try
to let it go as much as I can
because like you'll eat I don't know
what you're talking about because I
literally clean as I go
you are full of [__] there's times and
all the dishes in the sink right now
which one of those are mine okay zero
yes this is this is one of those times
where I'm saying I'm [__] tired of
cleaning
did you make the bed today of course not
yeah you never make the [__] bed yeah
so there's a lot of did you clean
anything in the house did you mop the
floor did you vacuum did you vacuum
inside this room did you clean all the
countertops I spilled some of my juice
and I wiped it yeah [__] off exactly so
I think I'm allowed one day out of three
months to do that [__] okay good okay
yeah anyway so we have one we have this
rule that if the the sink is clean Yeah
clean up your [__] yeah I call you out
on it and that's when you tell me I'm
sorry I was just in the zone and you
know I have ADHD so like I'm gonna I'm
gonna get to it I'm gonna do it later no
no no no no no no no
once we had that rule I'll keep this in
sync oh my God I'm gonna start taking
pictures take pictures because who left
that sink the way it is now not me yes
that's okay and I'm telling you that I'm
saying it's not me
that's all I'm saying right now but I'm
gonna show you times where everything is
spotless vlogging how many times have I
said Channel how many times oh you want
that yeah Vlog it put on the channel
because these people want to know the
truth all right show the receipts you do
it too then you get the receipts on me
but you better get the receipts too when
you see everything else being spotless
your ass can barely take care of yours
yourself in the cleanliness in your own
space yeah I'm doing everyone else's
[__] and guess what I'm gonna patch on
the back I don't need your [__] pets
I don't need your pets I just need you
to know that you need to cut me some God
[__] goddamn slack you see I can't
even speak I'm so emotionally rolled up
what the [__] are you like part of
McGregor's [__] camp and [__] you get
me all rolled up and I can't [__]
think straight in the cars don't blame
me it's you [__] this is the
cause but anyways that's how I confront
my battles you just created a whole new
[__] battle okay so my follow-up
question to that then yeah
ah man you pissed me off I don't even
know how I don't even know how you go oh
you know how I don't even know how we
got married from this point you [__]
robot [__] [__] tell me
um
okay
so this is all fun and games right like
it's never really that serious like this
bickering back and forth that you and I
are doing like it's to me at least it's
never something that's like gonna break
my relationship I got things to think
about oh my love to you what do you mean
it's what I got things
about reconsider
okay but seriously
um what do you do then
to not allow things or even if you do to
not allow things to pile up and then one
day you blowing up so that's something I
worked on too where I just have to say
it ASAP
because I think before you know like one
of my anger issues before is I would
feel like you know what I can suck this
up I can suck this up and it's on me and
I'll keep putting it on me
and then I realized one day I get pissed
and like let's say I'm in I'm having a
bad day things aren't going my way and
then you know like the the straw that
broke the camel's back like there'll be
one thing that is you if there if we had
like a visitor they would seem like what
the [__] Bart just exploded over that
but it's not right it's like the whole
con the combination and accumulation of
a bad day and then also that one thing
that happened now the thousandth time so
I don't let it get to a thousand times
now I bring it up as soon as I can but
also I try to follow the
um How to Win Friends and Influence
People Dale Carnegie way where I try not
to make things accusational because I
think that's like something I learned in
the past too where it's like you made me
feel like this yeah and but everyone in
their right mind is
doing things the right way everyone no
one like purposely goes this is a
mistake let's make some yeah everyone's
just living their life doing their thing
so everyone's the good guy in their
movie so you have to address the good
guy in their movie like they're the good
guy and so I think bringing things up in
a tactful way
um also is easier to bring things up
without making the other party feel
defensive and all of a sudden it turns
into a fight yeah when you're just
trying to bring up an issue that maybe
it could be better for both people you
know yeah you're actually really good at
that now now I am I feel like and to
kind of correct something I don't even
think you caught that you said is
um
no one has ever really seen you blow up
well they don't see me blow up but I
have in our relationship well for us
yeah in us but like never with friends
or anything no never no one has ever
seen you do that
um and I haven't even seen you blow up
since
Jesus
um since before we even thought of
having taika I guess like you right now
way before could I guess that you're
right right real quick okay so if no one
has ever seen me blown up besides you
[Laughter]
hahaha
oh my God I [__] hate this man
[Laughter]
I wish you could have seen your stupid
ass face
[Laughter]
I mean
I don't want to point fingers but this
[__]
no it's just you [__] had your own
issues yeah yeah and then I think like
um so I'm someone that likes to set the
standard no you're awesome
and really try to uphold it so anytime
that I have a new realization I'm like
oh so this is what's been causing me to
do this once I set that standard I
almost try to like I got it I'm gonna
die before I fail you and if I do feel I
feel really bad how do you remember
almost like 2x the efforts and then so I
haven't blown up since
I can't remember probably like I don't
know maybe four or five years or
something no way more than that because
taika tyke is about to be six yeah
so maybe like
I think we were still I think we that's
when we bought our first house I think
that was like the last time oh yeah the
first first one so what was that 20
15. yeah oh and going back to what I was
talking about how this also kind of like
picking and choose my battles made me a
better dad because talking about the
first house and then taika kind of
reminded me about that part of the
conversation
um one thing that I hated as a kid that
I didn't know that I hated until I
looked back was when I piss my mom off
as a kid
she would hold that against me the whole
day
so like let's say I [__] up let's say
I knocked this glass over right and then
we're gonna go to like I don't know Big
Bear or whatever we meet up with friends
we'll go to Big Bear and then the whole
day is like a cold shoulder oh damn
don't talk to me no snacks no dessert oh
no we went there to go skiing you're not
skiing you're gonna stand right the
whole day I got punished I think I was
punished until she felt good yeah and so
that's something that I actually learned
a lot from you because I'll see like
let's say
um
we're gonna go play basketball with
tiger he's going to go to basketball
practice he does something he's not
supposed to do in the morning
as soon as he's like reprimanded hey
blah blah blah you know you're supposed
to do this you can't do this blah blah
lectures done new moment we get in the
car attack it goes can we play a game
immediately you play the game because
and I'm like oh [__] I got I learned a
lot from that because that makes me
think of baby Bart that I'm like
yeah like once the Lessons Learned why
drag it out you know because it's not
like you can fix a kid in one time you
know you raising a kid is repetitive and
repetitive right so it's all the time so
just in the moment
this is what's wrong correction made
cool new moment let's get back to
getting close to as like a parrot and
kid as soon as possible so that also
helped me on like that made me a better
parent because now when I pick and
choose my battles I view it the same way
like
here's something that's
needs to be addressed address it
battle's done and then I don't make I
don't wage this war
that's constant for like a long long
long long time and I think that's just
probably due to uh my mom's own ability
to manage her emotions where
um because you know like this generation
we're way more emotionally intelligent
yeah and aware yeah so now like we can
actually go like oh [__] I'm feeling
angry but who's causing it is this
properly channeled and then kind of like
you know Jiu Jitsu our emotions versus I
think back then it's just my mom says
I'm just [__] frustrated well [__]
no I'm ain't talking to nobody the whole
[__] day you know and then the kids
the most innocent ones end up taking
like the brunt of it because they don't
even know what the [__] going on yeah
yeah so I actually learned a lot from
you from that
damn that's really cool I didn't even
realize I did that
um no I didn't have parents that did
that uh I only so for me it wasn't I
would get the cold shoulder
when it was something that I knew they
were so disappointed that I [__] up on
instead of something small like if it
was small I would get reprimanded then
and there and then we just move on
so I didn't I didn't have that
um and the other thing I think that
helped me was
owning pets really because I would I had
like birds that I trained dogs that I
trained cats that I trained and with
them I just realized that which they are
similar to kids where
you know they can only retain so much
information at any given moment because
they're either developing or their brain
is just that small or at least
um what I gauge to be that small that
like I was like okay they could only
have this attention for this amount of
time after that we gotta move on yeah so
that helped me
um but no you're really good at
at uh
having your aha moments or your
epiphanies and then like really trying
to stick to making that better like how
do you do that
how do I do that yeah the where you like
remember it like is it because it hits
you so hard and you're like oh [__] this
puzzle piece clicked so hard for me that
you can't even shake it
to even forget about it
I think I know who I want to be
and then who I want to become
and then when I like mess up or
something
I really get down on myself
so like I have a vision of like the type
of dad I want to be the type of Grandpa
I want to be and then so like let's say
with like the anger issues stuff when I
when I
um like let myself go in the moment I
get [__] pissed and like let's say I
throw the remote across the room or
whatever
afterwards when I calm down
I feel I get really down on myself as if
I committed like a cardinal sin as if I
cheated or as if I killed someone or you
know something huge like it feels that
big because
that type of person or that action is
not conducive to the person that I you
want to become I want to be so like even
though I'm not really like religious but
I I will repent
like to myself like I let myself what
does that look like
um I think I'll sit in my thoughts for a
long time and then almost like reverse
affirmations like no I don't go like
you're a [__] piece of [__] or
anything like that but like like um like
how the [__] can you do that like why
the [__] would you do is that is this
gonna make you the person that you want
to be you know like
and then and then and it's
very very ingrained and then I have a
very emotional reaction because I feel
like
um
like the word trauma or triggers I think
there's positive triggers and negative
triggers right yeah for sure positive
triggers could be like seeing the golden
arches of McDonald's you see it like ah
when I was a kid you know Happy Meal
just happened just you're so happy so I
feel like
um I try to make myself and I think
everyone has this but I try to be
trigger aware
oh cool yeah so like as soon as there's
a trigger I go
okay and I let it sit in that moment for
a quick second and I try to identify
what that trigger is and where it's
leading me to so like let's say we get
into another argument and I can feel
like oh [__] here's my blood boiling
trigger that's so cool alert I'm like is
this gonna make me
um become the grandpa and the dad that I
want to be or is like what is we had
this conversation already
what do I want to do you know and then
I'd be like
maybe I need to go outside and take a
break get some air breathe that's really
cool
how do you so because I think that's
probably the the I don't know what you
called yourself in the beginning of this
podcast but well I guess what I would
call the robot right yeah
um or I specifically said [__]
r-e-t-a-r-d
well I'm gonna call you the robot okay
um so you're looking at it as something
that's not ideal right because you're
going okay this specific trait of mine
is preventing me from making a really
deep connection with my wife who's the
love of my life and the most gorgeous
most intelligent most independent
successful woman I know yes all true
words yeah yeah yeah I I'm just quoting
you
um so you see it as something that's
preventing you from that right from this
connection but do you think that that
plays a role in how you're able to
slow things slow things down enough to
understand that there's a trigger that's
happening
what do you mean so right now you just
talked about uh you're very trigger
alert I try to be triggered yeah yeah
yeah you're not perfect yeah yeah so you
try to be trigger alert and there's
times where you catch yourself yeah how
often do you feel like percentage-wise
do you catch yourself in a in a trigger
moment positive or negative
um probably like 90 of the time okay
that's [__] high yeah
um do you think that this robotness of
yours is what helps that I think so
because I'm asking that because for me
I'm just feeling everything all the time
yeah yeah yeah you know that's why I can
look at someone and be like oh damn that
person's not doing good or I can walk
into a room and be like oh man this this
room feels really really good you know
like I'm very much aware of like
emotions and people's emotions and like
animals emotions like I have a
heightened heightened heightened sense
of energy all over me all the time and
because I'm constantly feeling it from
everything
that I don't I'm not as aware of what my
triggers are because I'm just kind of
like feeling it all out all the time and
it's not until I'm very much in the
depths of it whether it's pure Bliss or
like pure [__] chaos and negativity
then I'm going oh [__] I'm like stuck in
this thing like what happened and I have
to like I think that's why when we run
into a problem where you need to talk
about it right away I'm like I need to
crawl back out of this either super
Blissful moment or the super chaotic
moment and figure out what happened so
then I have to sit with myself and be
like okay let's reverse engineer where
things went straight or like how I
reached this peak of euphoria you know
yeah or the state of euphoria
so I have to sit there and then like
think about it
so that's so like you might see it this
robotness as something that's bad or or
preventing you from things but it's also
causing you to be very trigger aware
like 90 of the time yeah well you know
in the in um I think it was that Tony
Robbins seminar that we went to
where he talks about how people think
there's like stimulus
and then reaction
so the most oblivious people are like
well they did this I did that
right that's the most oblivious people
it's like the government's gonna do this
so [__] them back yeah this I do this
but then people that are slightly more
aware they know there's a stimulus
there's an emotion and then there's a
reaction so this happens I'm pissed and
then I react but in many cases those
guys still justify their reaction they
go well they did this made me pissed so
they blame it on someone else so but
that's second level awareness right
third level awareness is stimulus
emotion and then my decision to react
reaction yes right that's like the
highest level where even in like uh like
fighting someone throws a punch you
don't just Flinch you go okay here's the
punch coming what do I do what are my
tools do I block Perry slip what do I do
I pull it drop pull back so kind of like
that it's like this person did this at
the gas station
I can tell they're trying to be a dick
now with that information do I get mad
and Dick back or what are my decisions
or do I like that or back or do it yeah
or do I um
uh win them with kindness give them
something unexpected make both of our
days feel good what is my decision and
then
I react
so that's like tier three
I think my robotness allows me to be
more tier three
because I'm always like uh
I'm always in a state of meta
like you know for you it's like I'm in
the ocean so
like the waves are rocking the [__] out
of me I always know I'm on a boat I
always know there's a boat between me
and the ocean
so I always know if I want to get out of
this I gotta just steer the boat
somewhere else whereas I think most
people they're just in the turbulence
whereas I remember I'm in a vessel in
the turbulence so I think that's my my
buffer but then the con to that it's
also very very hard for me to be present
because even when I'm talking to you
most people are just like they talk to
them talk to the other person for me I
know I'm talking to you
huh say that again so most people when
they're talking or they're interacting
with people
they are just doing it
right that's why like if you hold my
hand I could feel I could hold your hand
we're just like we're one we're like
this uh like an improv show we're like
we're just in this Symphony
for me I know that I'm talking to you
I'm in third person
so I'm constantly judging myself even
right now am I crossing my legs the
right way am I holding my am I sitting
straight like I'm like I'm I'm meta I'm
in I am aware of what I'm doing and so
although it makes me a better robot it
makes me less reactive
the negative side to that is I'm not
very present
um you know versus like I'm sure like
you like let's say you go watch taika
like have a recital you're just like
enamored wow so cute he's doing this
he's doing such a great job it's just
feelings him feelings you feelings for
me I'm like I'm a dad at a recital
sitting in the third row watching my son
and then I have feelings
so I have all these like and what is
knowing but then so the good so the bad
side is it's hard for me to be present
the good side is if anything happens at
that State like let's say there's a fire
or whatever I remember I'm the dad
sitting in the third row now how do I
act because my emotions are so at Bay
because I have so much distance between
me and the emotion
yeah that's why even when you say like
when we have sex when I drink you're
like you think I'm a different person
because I think I'm present now because
now I'm just having sex
right I'm just [__] beating the [__]
up
versus before lucky me before I know I
am having sex I know I am beating the
[__] up
in that way maybe that's why it feels
robotic and maybe that's also why I get
in my own head because I am in my own
you [__] yourself up all the time
because I am in my own head because I'm
like
you know then I start thinking what do I
look like when I'm having sex am I even
doing it good instead of just doing it
good or being in the moment I'm thinking
about I'm almost like watching me do
what I'm doing in third person Jesus you
know yeah but then you can see why when
you watch yourself in third person you
could be like yo bar you're about to be
angry again like because then you're so
trigger aware yeah
so that's like the
yeah yeah yeah pros and cons everything
has a negative and a positive to it yeah
um I love the way you explain that
if you had to choose being one way
versus the other
where it's mine where you're just in it
you're feeling it you're very present
you're very connected versus meta third
person what would you prefer I prefer
mine why because I look at like majority
of the world as unstable creatures
oh [__] you even if it prevents you from
having really deep connections with
people
that's the part that kind of sucks
where like
um
like sometimes I feel like I I wish I
could connect with people on a deeper
level what does that look like to you
deeper level
like
like the way that I because I can feel
it you know I feel like I have like
I feel like I make friends with a condom
mod
you make friends with the condom on yeah
what does that mean like I'm not raw
dogging what does that mean like let's
say with me and David right like
um me and them are very very close
and then when we hug and I like with
this I feel like there's still a [__]
layer between us of latex
that coming from both of you or just
from you I think mainly for me I can
feel it that's mainly for me
that like like you know friends that are
forged over like drinking at the bar
just arm over arm and then they're just
walking through the streets just having
a good time I feel like that's like the
deepest connection and
um a lot of people can do that sober
because they're just in it but for me
um
it's it's so rare you know it always
feels like I think he likes me and I
think I like him
and I think we're connecting but you
know there's a condom on the whole time
and I can feel the condom
what what also because I've been on
ecstasy
so I know what condomless feels like and
I think that's what normal people feel
but isn't that very common
isn't that why people like to drink like
after you know like after work let's go
grab a drink because all inhibitions are
down yeah you don't think you're normal
I for sure know I'm not because I think
me on alcohol is people connecting
normally
well you want alcohol knocks out so I
don't even I don't think I've ever even
seen you on well for the five first five
minutes okay I think that's how people
connect normally
I don't know if you really change really
or what about me on ecstasy
you're not like
I don't know you on ecstasy is still
very much you
but now you can just Express
and understand what other people are
feeling and that's how strong my [__]
retardation is
I wouldn't call it that because it's so
strong even when I'm on ecstasy I'm bar
on ecstasy yeah you're very close people
are just oh I'm [__] rolling I'm like
I'm on ecstasy roll like I still have
that layer it's thinner and thinner and
thinner maybe I need to be on a crazy
ass dose but like whatever yeah you
don't seem very good syndrome I have
yeah
it's so strong that I'm still a little
bit meta but then I can feel
like
um I can feel what I think other people
feel like you know yeah no you're uh
yeah I've done a few things with your
like like we've done a few like we've
done mushrooms we've done ecstasy and
yeah you don't ever feel like you're not
bark
do I ever feel like I'm not Geo
I think I feel pretty controlled
but your regular is already [__]
this [__] Goliath had [__] Six
Flags human yeah okay
because you're already [__] crazy
what does that mean what do you mean
crazy like just [__] Loops ups and up
up and down yeah to you it probably
feels unstable as [__] huh yeah yeah
yeah
most people feel very unstable and
extremely impulsive to me
most people
now I guess I guess yours is pretty cool
but like yeah with everything there's a
give and take yeah and I like being the
way I am because I I can uh and I
appreciate you the way you are because
it teaches me a lot about how to feel
how to be present because I see the
connections that you guys make
and it's almost as if like um
like let's say I see you with one of our
closest friends and you guys are talking
and I can literally feel and see you
guys get closer and I'm like wow but for
me I'm like wow two people are moving
their lips with audible sounds
and for some reason there's this
closeness in the air that I cannot quite
describe like you're absolutely Drax and
I'm like let me let me Guardians of the
Galaxy I will attempt to participate
[Laughter]
Retreat that was not very successful at
all you're literally dressed like that I
think it's like that went over your head
and then you're like
I didn't see anything nothing nothing
goes over my head there's clear skies
right now
lucky me no but on the flip side like
yeah your personality or just how your
robotness
um is definitely something like stable
for me
and I think that's probably what makes a
relationship
so good
is that like I'm a crashing wave and
you're a rock yeah but then when you're
a rock these waves are very soothing for
you and then like they help you
understand [__] and they like wash away
all your stress
and your dishes when I tell you to
[__] pick up after yourself
I'll go back to that huh
yeah let that [__] go
yeah I think we complement each other
and we probably teach each other a lot
and we also frustrate each other a
[__] on because
we're so different and we see things
differently yeah that you're just like
this [__] is
just stable as [__] and then I'm going
this [__] rock-headed [__]
Drax [__] doesn't got [__]
you know what's kind of cool though that
helps me relate with people is my food
urges
that's what really helps me relate with
people explain so like let's say if my
food and my diet choices were just as
locked in as the rest of my life I think
I would be completely unrelatable
because I'll be like
oh how can we missed your workout you
know like oh dude I was [__] jet like
I just flew in yesterday it's [__]
3am I'm like 3M so what you said you're
gonna train on Tuesday right you'll be
like that yeah
you want to be like oh wait you see
you're gonna save money like a thousand
bucks a month
you know my friend he just got cancer he
beat cancer so I wanted to get him a
present I'm like but you said you're
gonna save a thousand dollars a month
you just you just [__] lied
you know oh yeah and you like saying and
then I'll be like what the [__] like
dude yes it's so undisciplined you
literally Gonna Save a thousand dollars
a month just because your front beat
cancer you're gonna go spend 500 bucks
and then so it makes I'm such a [__]
robot you know like whatever's
programmed as my zeros and ones it needs
to be my zeros at once but with my food
stuff I'm a [__] Maniac I'm a [__]
crack addict right like I I can't wait
to cheat on my [__] food I feel very
impulsive I tell myself I'm gonna be on
that diet and I [__] see one
pepperoni and I go oh my God what the
[__] so like I think that's how I relate
because that's true that's how I feel
like regular humans are they say they're
gonna do something
do you get tested everyone fails and so
I think like by me trying to figure out
how to stay disciplined even with my own
diet I'm like oh that's the that's the
difficulty that most people have most
people obviously have goals most people
obviously want to have a good life be
successful stick to what they're gonna
say but when life happens life happens
and it's very hard and I'm like that's
how I kind of relate myself to those
things
damn there's a human side to you after
all yeah or else I'd be [__] ripped
and I wouldn't be fat for the last 10
years
well you're not fat that's for sure I
mean yeah you've had your really big
moments but you're not fat
but yeah I'm happy that there's
something that is very human about you
and we're drawing and I'm and we're
painting an extreme picture here because
you're not like that unrelatable you're
not that uh robotic oh if I was I'd be
diagnosed with some [__] but I am
literally like knocking out the [__]
borders door
hello
anybody there should I come in now or if
I got further diagnosed I probably do
because I've already been diagnosed with
ADHD and all the other crazy [__] OCD
whatever and then I think I've heard
enough I left and you probably kept
talking they probably kept saying and
and and I just left already so I
probably have more [__] yeah yeah
I don't know you seem fine to me
you seem all right to me
maybe high functioning I don't know yeah
maybe that's where your mom came in and
[__] kept you in line
I do think see myself falling back to
those tools though my mom did help me a
lot what tools just those like super
crazy like Buddhist like monk for a day
crazy meditative like those type of
tools like extreme like control tools
because like I'll see myself Panic or I
feel like certain things and like I feel
like I can almost reduce anxiety at will
so it like it helps out
with being able to like Center yourself
yeah as they say yeah because when I go
when I go to those like being monk for a
day it's like you know you're gonna be
meditating for four hours
so you just gotta like embrace it now
and how do you live in it versus when
you're regular meditating and it's like
only 10 minutes or like [__] that's
what the [__] am I gonna do for 17 more
minutes oh Jesus is [__] crazy you
know kind of like people's flights for
the first time if you're used to doing
one or two hour flights your first
international flight you're like 13
hours what the [__] am I gonna do for 13
hours but you do those enough you find
the Rhythm yeah yeah 13 hours each year
take a nap I wake up boom I'm there yeah
and you do that enough now you know how
to occupy that time and I think I've
done a lot of that kind of exercising
with my mom that like when a stressful
situation comes I can like you know like
in the movies or the [__] ketchup
like the it's like floating in the air
the ketchup like when the car [__]
crashes oh you see the and then like
yeah like the person that is comfortable
is like in the slow motion and
comfortable with the slow motion versus
oh my God you know so I feel like
because of all those tools my mom gave
me when it's like crazy I can go and go
okay I know what I'm supposed to do yeah
that's awesome yeah I don't have any of
that
I'm going
like what the [__] oh [__] I'm getting
wrecked
yeah your mom's freaking she equipped
you pretty well yeah you had a shitty
childhood from how you explain it but
damn the tools you have now it's they're
remarkable yeah just long-term
investment
sucks ass at the beginning but I think
I'm finally collecting my checks like 30
years later which is pretty cool yeah
because it's when it matters thanks Mom
yeah I see you got to be nicer to your
mom I tried to everyone's got to be nice
to their mom yeah
and they're Pops I guess if they're
around
even if they're not around you don't
think about your pops you always think
about your pops there's times where [__]
will happen
um that I can recall my dad telling me
about that [__] and I'm like
damn it you were right thanks pops and
I'm always talking to them all the time
I'm still nice to him
you wanna do that
um
I even think I think my dad for the most
is the living up to a standard I think
that's where I got that from
like my dad smoked for like 40 years
whatever and then he found that I smoked
in junior high and he goes we're
quitting together cold turkey 40 years
yeah
and we started smoking when he was eight
remember yeah
so he's just boom if he's he's the guy
that goes like if you think I'm [__]
stable
I mean at the end we found out my dad's
unstable
but if you think I'm stable
oh my God my dad is like
he says something it's done it's [__]
done like the craziest [__] I've ever
seen my dad do my dad used to work night
shift so he would go to work at the
casino his shift from like six to like 2
A.M 6 p.m to 2 A.M and you come back
home when I first got kicked out of
school my dad says
um come wake me up in the room and you
know like high school you got to get
there at seven
so I go to my dad's room at 6am and as
soon as I tap him on the shoulder no
grogginess no like
that feet on the floor stand up let's go
every single day for that year damn my
dad says he's gonna do something he just
does it
that's what he thought I was such a fun
[__] because he's like what do you mean
you can't stick to what you're gonna say
so yeah your parents are both extreme so
my dad I think taught me a lot about
like if you say you're gonna do it then
you better do it yeah that's awesome
so I thank Kim a lot for that that's
pecuni yeah that's a good way to end
this podcast and a very CUNY know
because it started
it started rough in the beginning dude I
was about to like
feed you to to Tamia I was beating up
those mental meat flaps
you heard me no I didn't I told me is
there anything else you want to add to
the list of [__] I'm gonna [__] rub
in your face later nope nope okay what
about our sponsors
thank you for listening to our podcast
we always love sharing our vulnerable
moments of our relationship with you and
this podcast is made possible by our
brand bottle Brigade if you ever need
some dope clothes we always have
launches every single month so go check
that out we just dropped we're about to
drop our La summer collection which is
super La inspired we got palm trees City
Line and three new colors of mesh shorts
so go check that out we also recently
just dropped our strength stack which is
our unique ex our unique creatine blend
in my opinion that puts us in the top
Echelon of supplements because we have a
bunch of other creatine enhancers that
we put in there and we have our stud
muffins program so go to barbergate.com
and check that all out see you guys next
time thank you bye